at it once
again ladies and gentlemen daddy is back
and you know what we
do ladies and
gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite
podcast
w
[Music]
G I'm
aad what's up y'all as you know I had a
kid I'm a
dad so I'm going to talk about the dad
Journey right now and things I know now
things I wish I would have known and
then uh Super Bowl preview and you know
and then uh that'll be it but I
appreciate y'all being here as usual
sorry that I took a week off but you
know how it is I'll tell you about
[Music]
it I'm
aad what's up everybody Welcome to
riffing with
Griffon all appreciate everybody being
here um where is my damn there it is
okay my uh Mouse is gone I'm tired and
you know why but uh I appreciate
everybody being here thanks thanks for
it as always you know um subscribe make
sure you subscribe share uh hit the
notifications button that's how you're
going to know when I'm going live I
usually go live on
Wednesdays uh and I'm TW I usually
twitch most days probably won't be every
day now you know having a baby and all
but here's the thing too on Mondays I
also have some some extra podcast
material I've been saying I'm going to
do it and I've been doing it and I've
been consistent so if you want to be a
twitch subscriber you could get you can
watch it live on Twitch or you can be a
patreon member and you'll get that
content right there too and I'm putting
up pictures and messages about
everything on uh the patreon so make
sure you hit me up on there on patreon
too all the links are in the profile so
I appreciate
the support from everyone and speaking
of support everyone I want to say we
have our new
sponsor uh give it up to Robin Hood
Robin Hood our new sponsor if you only
have a 401k you're not getting the most
for retirement and an IRA then boosted
by 3% with Robin Hood and if you
transfer in any retirement account you
get 3% on top of that there's no limit
to the match Robin Hood gold gets you
the biggest contribution match of any
Ira on the market sign up for Robinhood
gold at robinhood.com SL boost by April
30th subscription fees apply and now for
some legal info investing involves risk
3% match requires gold for one year from
first match must keep Ira for 5 years
match on transfers subject to additional
terms and conditions Robin Hood
Financial LLC member
sic thank you Robin Hood Robin
Hood okay so make sure you sign up for
that
um so anyways
guys welcome to Griffin with Griffin yes
guess what I got a
kid oh man and it is amazing it's
absolutely amazing um I don't even know
what else I don't even know what else to
say you know what I mean don't even know
what else to say um you know let's give
it a little let's give it a little give
a little peeky peek of one of my
pictures I have you know get a little
picture get a little picture oh look at
that little cutie
pie it's my kid it's my
seed
uh little Wolford Wolford Garnett
Griffin y'all Wolford Garnett Griffin
so um yeah guys so we did it you know
I've been talking about it for months
and months and months and it finally
happened uh you know it wasn't
necessarily the smoothest uh birth but
you know he's here Rachel's great the
baby's great you know everything's uh
going good right now so you know we'll
see uh where it leads where where it
takes us but you know it is what it is
so he was born on February 1st 2024
obviously uh February 1st and then you
know we were in the hospital we got
there on Tuesday and we were let out on
wed Friday so it was like a long process
but I'll talk about all that we'll get
into it and
um you know we'll see how it goes uh you
know as we go along throughout the
podcast so but today I am going to talk
about the Super Bowl since it's coming
up this weekend want to give my picks
this is going to be the first weekend in
like Super Bowl in many many years not
counting to
covid that I went to Vegas you know so
other than the pandemic I would go to
Vegas every year for the Super Bowl so
you know what I mean it's like it's
crazy um that and it's actually in Vegas
this year so that's kind of like I'm
like what it's in Vegas and I'm not
going to be able to go so it is what it
is so um yeah so let me just go into
like so I'm going just go go into it all
guys uh you know about uh the everything
that's happened being a new dad how it
makes me feel uh you know things I
didn't know that I wish I knew uh you
know I'm no expert you know because I
hate when people do that too like
everybody that has a kid thinks they're
now an expert at kids it's like I had
ACL surgery it I it don't mean I know
everything about knees now just because
I had some surgery you know but you know
it is a it is a process for all you
people out there that want to have a kid
who are about to have a kid I'll tell
you what I went through I'm just talking
about for me as a dad as the dad as the
husband as the you know father of the
child whatever your situation is I don't
know um so shout out to Wiggy too by the
way Wiggy my dude he just had a baby he
we had we had like we're like five days
apart it's crazy that him and I have a
kid he could be my son that's how old he
is now he has a kid too so but anyway
shout out to wigs love you man um yeah
so you know like I said I normally go
into comments stuff like that but I
don't think I'm even going to look at
well I guess we can look at a few
comments you know it's just a lot of
congratulations and um you know people
normal haters and all that kind of stuff
in the chat so yeah you know what we're
not even gonna we won't even get into uh
that let's just start it so you know
fatherhood it's it's a crazy thing man
you know it's like I think that by
Nature it's designed uh the like the
nine months is by Design if you really
think about it like yeah you know it's
like yes the baby has to like grow and
but I think that the outside of the baby
what's happening in your relationship
with this person you're growing in that
you're preparing uh you're doing
physical preparation like you're you're
fixing up the house but you're also
mentally preparing you really are
mentally preparing for this this huge
transition in your life I mean if it
wasn't like that it would be like how
would it be imagine if you like you with
your girl and you decide you want to
have a baby and she's like I think I
want to have a baby and you go you sure
she's like like I I think I'm sure and
you guys go oh this would be great and
you're in the middle of this heartfelt
moment about how you going to have a
baby and then somebody rings the
doorbell ding dong and then somebody
opens the door and you're and they have
a baby they're like hey yeah here's the
baby you was asking for you'd be like
wait what we're not even ready what are
you talking about and then you have this
baby and if it if it worked like that I
don't know if people would keep the baby
I think people might change their mind
but there is that there's a there's a a
nesting process there's a your mind
starts to really as it gets closer and
closer as you watch your wife like grow
and change and all the things that
happens to her and the hormones and you
know and you're preparing for that too
you're you know you're learning patience
you know you're learning patience and
understanding and and and selflessness
because there's a thing about when a
woman is pregnant and all that she's
going through your needs and wants and
desires have to kind of put on a bag
burner while you're helping her grow
your child and and you want to make sure
she's fed and you know so that's part of
the process too of like you preparing to
be a
father you know providing you know and
that's what you're you're you're you're
training yourself during that process
you know and so we went through the
whole thing and then it's like you know
you go through this thing of like all
these tests and then you know you're
worried is your kid going to be okay is
your kid going to have something like
when I was born I had a procedure I had
something when I was born it's called h
sprungs it's uh something about your my
intestines were messed up and you know I
had to have surgery as a baby and you
know you have to have a colostomy bag it
was crazy you know when I when I think
about what my mom must have went through
when when I was born now that I've seen
this process must have been just like
you know so kudos to my mom you know
what I mean um yeah you know so you
worried about all that is your baby
going to be okay is your baby going to
have like down syndrome or whatever the
things are that they look for you know
what I mean defects or you know like
they going to have two arms and two legs
are they going to have like proper
shaped whatever I mean these are all
things that you're now concerned about
and you have to like mentally and
emotionally prepare yourself for
whatever is about to happen you know and
you're doing all that through the whole
nine months and I just think that that
let that process if you're if you're
thinking about this it's a beautiful
process and I'm telling you guys out
there that you know you have to like
understand uh you know the craziness
that is happening in your woman's body
like you know she's
like my God just the hormones just
everything all that stuff man you just
have to enjoy like somebody said in the
chat enjoy the process that is what you
have to do um you know you just you have
to you just have to go through that and
see what happens so you know so now the
day comes you know so we went to the
hospital on Tuesday so here's here's
something that I that I that I
learned you know when they say they they
go like you hear somebody talk about
Labor you know and then somebody will be
like yeah my wife was in labor or you
your mom like if your mom told you you
know you took a long time I was in labor
for 38 hours or it took 48 hours to
deliver you you know up until this point
I thought that that meant they were
laying on a table and they were pushing
for 48 hours and the doctors must have
had to take breaks to come in you know
that's what I thought I was like is that
what that means you know and it's like
no it's now I I understand what it means
you know it's like the moment that a
woman is dilated at all meaning that her
cervix is starting to expand and prepare
for birth when that process starts that
counts as labor so that's the labor and
she could be going through pain painful
contractions and however everybody's
different but that's what that means
guys that don't know and then you know
the cervix great they want it to be at
10 cm which isn't even that big man it's
really like like that it's crazy that a
baby comes through that but anyways you
know that's the process that happens and
once it gets to 10 centimeters then the
actual birth starts and and sometimes
that could be like boom 45 minutes to an
hour or even less sometimes somebody's
just ready or they having a little baby
they having like a six s PB baby and it
just Falls right out of there um you
know or like with us we had a
9.5 lb baby yes this baby would big you
I mean I'm 63 Rachel's 6 foot you know
her father's 7 foot you know almost 7
foot so we had a big ass baby so anyways
so our labor process started Tuesday
night okay so Rachel was in labor from
Tuesday to Friday morning um I'm sorry
Thursday the first whatever the first
was sorry the first but then they let us
out the or was it Wednesday I think it
was Wednesday whatever day the first was
okay um yeah so anyways we're there you
know a lot of stuff is going on you know
they're giving her stuff and you know
we're trying to figure out what's
happening and it doesn't happen when we
thought it was going to happen but we
have to stay in the hospital so now
she's going through her labor she's just
laying in this bed and then I'm I'm
laying on this like crazy cot they don't
care about the dads just so you know
dads they don't give a they don't care
you like they want you to if they could
they'd be like yeah stand in the corner
until she gives birth uh you know but
you know it was three days yeah yeah
okay you know you know it's crazy but at
least the birth room and we just was at
Cedars and shout out to all the staff at
Cedars they were great magnificent
people um but you know you're in this
like room and so in the birthing room
you at least have like a somewhat decent
sleeping arrangement for the dad you
know it wasn't like the Four Seasons but
crazy I'll tell you about postpartum
later that was a crazy anyways so we're
waiting waiting waiting waiting waiting
waiting and then it's like uh I believe
it was like Tuesday uh th what did we
get in there did we get Monday no we
went when no I'm so confused now we went
Tuesday yes we went in Tuesday and we
left Friday so all right so it was like
Wednesday night you know it was like all
right they checked her she was like like
three cmet you know which is you know
all right we're like damn what's going
on when is this going to happen and then
it was the next morning you know and
Rachel was in pain and she you know she
wanted to epidural and it was like all
kinds of things happening in terms of
that I won't give you a lot of details
cuz she doesn't like that um and then we
um all right so then the Midwife comes
in so this is how it happened for me I'm
going to tell you from the dad's
perspective I'm sitting here looking at
my wife you know on this table obviously
in pain but pain is good because that
means something's happening and this
Baby's about to go out come out right so
we're sitting there the Midwife comes in
with the two nurses and they're just
doing a routine check there you know our
doctor is not going to be there yet
until it's time your doctor don't show
up until it's like there ready to do
like boom and in case there's anything
going on they're ready to go right
Midwife checks you know what they do
they check your wife's cervix they you
know they put a glove on and they go in
there and they feel around so it's like
whatever morning the morning of the 1
and we're just sitting there kind of
like okay let's see what happens and
then the do Midwife goes guess what your
wife's 10 centimeters Rachel you're 10
centimeters let's just start you know
and I'm like what what do you mean start
okay so then they go uh you know I'm
standing there and they're like oh Dad
hold her leg I'm like hold her leg like
I'm I'm not supposed to be in the
wedding room with a
cigar you know what I mean they're like
no no no you need to hold her leg so the
other nurse holds her leg the Midwife
standing in front of her and she's like
all right let's do some practice pushes
because they can see the contractions on
the machine and like on the on the
contraction we're going to practice push
just like you know and so she does it
she I'm holding her leg up I'm looking
at her face all scrunched up and she
just like clearly like oh my God and
then she starts to push you know what I
mean and then the the Midwife is excited
she's like oh my God you're doing great
this Baby's about to come right now and
I'm like what are you talking about so
then they call the doctor the doctor's
on the way and we're just you know and
she's pushing I'm just and then I lock
eyes with this like I I felt
like I felt like Luke Skywalker on the
boat and return to the Jedi and the
sarlac pit was you know you know what I
mean and the doctor the Midwife and the
doctor are like Jaba over there and I'm
you know
like they about to push me into this pit
right and I but I couldn't look away
this is the crazy part I couldn't look
away so then the doctor finally gets
there and Rachel's been pushing and it's
happening you know so I'm in a I'm in a
days man I'm just like I lock eyes with
the with with with
this cavernous hole that the baby's
about to come out you know that's what
you just think you're just like what
happened to my wife like what is that
down there you know what I mean you're
looking at that like are you kidding me
what's that so then you know and then
you know the baby's head which I didn't
realize was starting to it was there and
the doctor's playing with my baby's hair
you know like and I'm like what are we
talking about you know and then it's
just like you see the baby's head and
you think well how is the rest of this
baby going to come out of there cuz if
you think about like this is my head and
these are my shoulders how these
shoulders going to get even if I did
like this my shoulders I couldn't make
my shoulders be the sides of my
head man and then it's like it it it
happened like in 45 50 minutes you know
of me having to hold her leg and then
this baby comes sliding out and it's
just like a purple monster you know what
I mean and then everybody then everybody
takes action you know nurses are wiping
and the baby's already pooping and it's
like and and a baby poop when it first
comes out it's like this black tar it's
like this real tar substance the baby's
pooping and peeing and I'm in shock you
know what I mean and I'm just looking
and they wipe her baby off and they put
the baby right on Rachel's chest you
know and she's such a crybaby so she's
just like oh my God relieved I don't
know if she's crying because she's
finally not pregnant anymore or if she's
crying because she's finally meeting her
son and it's just like I am just baffled
I I come over to her face and I just
look at her and I just have like an
outpouring of love like I you know you
love your wife man but when you see her
do this for your family your emotions
for her go like through the roof you
know and then you see your kid and
you're just like oh my God you know what
I mean you're you just want to grab your
kid and be like [__] get out the way
you know you know what I'm saying
because it's like it's so much emotions
and you know so they're dealing with her
and then you know dealing with the baby
then it's like then stuff start to
happen like Rachel's like really
bleeding a lot you know what I mean and
so then you know that's all I say that
it was like it was it was tense in there
you know so I had to take the baby I had
this like button- down shirt so I got
the baby on my chest and I'm sitting
over here I'm looking at what's going on
man and I'm just like then it's like a a
a a season finale of graay anatomy all
of a sudden you know there's like nine
doctors in there and one's screaming at
another like what's going on and you
know this one's doing that and they're
telling and they're working in unison
and they're like you know is she
allergic to anything and they're like
they they're you know they're getting
this together and and I'm I'm starting
to be like oh I don't want to panic I
don't want to put Panic onto the kid you
know what I mean so I'm trying to just
be like you know I'm singing Lion King
songs and [__] you know what I mean I'm
over here in the
corner you know what I mean and then the
doctor comes over and then she's
absolutely fabulous and she's like Eric
she's going to be fine everything's
going to be fine I promise you she's
going to be okay you know and it kind of
put me at ease a little bit but it's
just like until she was I was like okay
what's going
on you know what I mean and so uh and
then you know she was everything was
fine she got the baby and then like her
mom's there she's taking pictures and
then her mom this is the funniest part
of her mom's FaceTiming Rachel's dad you
know and he's like you know he's he's
like I can't see show me the you put the
camera on the ba on the baby you know so
they're like having this funny argument
on the phone he all I hear is his voice
you know what you know what I mean
so it was just a funny when we finally
got settled in it was great you know and
then you go to the then you go to
postpartum and then we had to go to a
special postpartum because they had to
monitor her they had to make sure Rachel
was okay and we have to make sure this
Baby's okay so now you're in this other
room so now the original room I'm in has
a little cot a little like it's like a
couch that stretches and you put the
pillows from the couch to make yourself
a bed in the postpartum room I'm the
what they had for the dads in a much
smaller room I I was in like a Spirit
Airline
economy seat you know and this is what
I'm supposed to sleep in for two more
three more two or three more days it was
the worst and then of course Rachel and
I we overpack so I got snacks for days I
got all this stuff you know I mean you
know and we're in this little room now
and at the same time we have to take
care of this baby they just leave the
baby with you like good luck you know
what I mean so you have to like learn
how to swaddle and I you know I'm
changing diapers and I'm just kind of
like you know just like in a in a in
like a haze of like oh my God here we
are you know and
so you know after that then you you know
you come home you know so they let us
come home and we were ready and that's a
credit to Rachel we were ready Rachel
had the nursery ready we had the the the
the we have a orbit stroller you know we
we had all the things she had the
drawers already set up she had we had
diapers already all over the place we
had all different sizes of things we had
the wipes we had the changing tables we
had like all of this stuff that I've
been seeing for like the past few months
and I'm just kind of like all right you
know I'm like damn girl let me see the
bill you know that's you know it's all
the money but then I see it now I'm like
oh that's what this was all for
preparing and we were ready we just were
ready we got home with the baby we did
it and we just did it man and I think
that like you know you got to be you got
to have to that first of all I don't
understand how
anybody it must I'll say this it must be
super difficult to have a baby with
someone that you don't really know going
through this preprocess must be a
nightmare because you really have to
like trust this like you it's a Rel it's
a it's a dance you're doing of like
making sure everything is okay making
sure she's okay and and setting up and
preparing yourself emotionally and and
all the things that you have to do it's
crazy I can't even imagine how people do
it with just you know oh I got my side p
he's pregnant or or I got a one night
stand it's like you are you oh man wow I
couldn't even imagine but you know and
then we didn't sleep the first night was
tough it's been tough it's slowly gotten
better
um you know and we just we're just doing
it you know just next thing you know
you're just a parent and then you have
to like so luckily I'm in a position
where I don't have to like I'm not I
don't I don't work at some Fortune 500
company or I own a a store where I have
to be there I'm in a great position in
my life right now where I could just be
here with her and I'm slowly doing
things you know I'm going doing my
podcast and I'm taking this month off
from like traveling or even going to the
clubs uh to do standup and uh you know
and we'll see how it goes and but it's
just you know ra Rachel's killing it I
mean just killing and her post
postpartum has been great that there was
no depression or weird hormonal things
things she's been great like a trooper
just like on
it um you know what I mean so it's
just I like to start every sentence now
with as a
father as a
father you know it be like now I'm
looking at I'm looking at like potholes
I'm looking at like where the stop signs
are I'm looking at people how they
driving I'm look it's just like all the
things you start to think about but I
can't really Express the overwhelming
sense of love like I don't I don't know
if I've I didn't know what it meant to
really you think you know what it means
to love someone like you're going to
love your wife you love your mom your
mom's probably the closest thing to it
for some but some people don't even have
a good relationship with their mom I
don't know what it is I can't describe
it like I say I have this o
burning just love a Burning Flame of
love for Rachel you know what I mean I
really do and it and it
magnified because of
this but when you think about your son
you think about your
kid if I had to
choose I would
perform the Temple of
Doom sacrifice Rachel would be in that
thing and I would be like khma you know
what I mean like you got to go cuz
Wolfie and she would do the same to me
I'm sure right
we just in love with this kid so you
know I just find myself crying for no
damn
reason uh you know I just love taking
pictures I love the little outfits you
put them in every little outfit I'm like
oh my God this is adorable you know what
I mean every little outfit you know and
I just like I don't know guys it's just
it's am oh I love this like carrier oh
my God I love this thing I'll show you
guys this this thing is great I love
this little Carri you know the little um
whatever the hell this is whatever that
is the little carrier he's just in there
I'm I'm walking around the house I'm
gaming I'm doing stuff while he's just
sleep it's just the most adorable
Fascination uh but his and the people
that want to know his name his name is
Wolford Garnett
Griffin now the crazy thing is like I
named him we I was looking
for um I was looking
for a G name as you guys know if you've
been following the podcast you know my
middle name's Graham Rachel's middle
name's Greta so we I wanted a g name for
my kid wolfford is Rachel's grandfather
Rachel's grandfather so we named him
that it's not Wilford it's wolf Wolford
so um I was like okay we gonna name him
Wolford I'm fine with that we'll call
him wolf we'll call him Wolfie I'll call
him dub you know what I mean dub you
know what I mean for dub W you know so
um but I said I want a g name and so
when we saw that it was going to be
January Rachel found we've been
searching for names and she finally came
up with this Garnett and Garnett is the
birth stone of January because we
thought he was going to be born in
January and I was like I love that I but
but but before when she first said
Garnett I was like oh what you know
about my favorite basketball player cuz
my favorite basketball player of all
time is Kevin garette so I was like this
is perfect yeah let's name him Garnett
you know what I mean but it turns out
and we're not even spelling it like
Kevin Garnett but it's like Garnett the
stone even though he's born in February
so yeah but that's it so it's Wolford
Garnett Griffin and I'm excited and I'm
going to keep you guys updated on the
journey things I'm learning and stuff
like that as the as the months go on you
know but as a dad something that I have
to think about now is finances everybody
finances are important okay did you know
that even if you have a 401k for
retirement you can still have an IRA
Robin Hood has the only Ira that gives
you a 3% boost on every dollar you
contribute when you subscribe to Robin
Hood gold but get this now through April
30th Robin Hood is even boosting every
single dollar you transfer in from other
retirement accounts with a 3% match
that's right no cap on the 3% match
Robin Hood gold gets you the most for
your retirement thanks to their Ira with
a 3% match this offer is good through
April 30th get started at robinhood.com
booost subscription fees apply and now
for some legal info claim as of quarter
2024 validated by radius Global
Marketing research investing involves
risk including loss limitations apply to
IRAs and 401ks 3% match requires Robin
Hood gold for one year from the date of
first 3% match must keep Robin Hood for
Robin Hood Ira for 5 years the 3%
matching on transfer subject to specific
terms and conditions Robin Hood Ira
available to us customers in good
standing Robin Hood Financial LLC member
sic is registered broker dealer thank
you Robin Hood for being my first ad of
2024 more to
come
um all right guys enough baby talk uh
let's get into uh the Super Bowl y'all
the Super Bowl Super Bowl's coming who
you got I'mma tell you who I got um I
think it's a great fantastic match I
think that the ners have been a great
team for like five or six years and here
they are once again in the Super Bowl
with we don't know if he's a better
quarterback or not than Jimmy G this guy
was the last pick in the draft Brock pie
and so can he do it he's been playing
great he was he was considered the MVP
you know 12 13 14 weeks into the season
so we'll see you know can he do it it's
going to say a lot but they have been
the best team all year up to the point
they got smacked around by the Ravens
but then the Ravens showed their true
colors so you know they're the this is
the best on paper the 49ers are the best
team still playing okay they are a much
better team on paper than the Kansas
City Chiefs I think I think that they
have seven or eight or nine all Pros
49ers uh just skill position players all
over the place offense defense play you
know offensive defensive players of the
year here uh on either side of the ball
so we'll see okay so they are a great
team and then you have the Kansas the
the Kansas City Chiefs who with Patrick
Mahomes arguably one of the greatest
quarterbacks ever he's probably already
in the top three top five greatest
quarterbacks ever six straight AFC
championship games uh two Super Bowl
victories already been to four he could
have three if he wins this one he's got
Travis kelsley arguably the greatest
tight end of all time uh and the and
probably the greatest coach ever in Andy
Reid if you think it's Bill bellich but
then I saw a thing on one of the sports
shows the other day that Andy Reid's
actually got he's he's he's approaching
Bill balichek's numbers in terms of wins
and you know and all that kind of stuff
uh so he just has the six Super Bowls
but we're already thinking that it was
because of Brady not belich uh right so
now but Andy Reed is the you know he
wins everywhere right so you got that
team who's been struggling all year
receivers dropping passes here and there
terrible losses on the on on the thing
but then the playoffs come and they put
it together and this all World
quarterback put the team on his back and
still had faith in these receivers who
have been dropping passes all year
clutch and now they are back in the
Super Bowl Against All Odds it's crazy
but I tell you what I ain't voting
against Patrick Mahomes I'm not going to
do it so my pick is the Chiefs I think
the Chiefs are going to win the Super
Bowl I think that the 49ers they're not
going to they they just they're not GNA
have enough you know it's just
something's going to go wrong because
that's what happens with Patrick Mahomes
I think he's going to win his third
Super Bowl in Seven Seasons or six
seasons whatever it is right his third
Super Bowl in six
seasons I if if you just go off eye test
it if if you were Drafting and you could
see their careers in the first let's say
10 years of their careers right but
let's just go six CU he's only been
playing six years who would you take
Brady's first six years or Patrick
Mahomes first six years it's not even
close you would take Patrick Mahomes
MVPs 50 touchdowns if he wins three
Super Bowls but even the two Super Bowls
are fantastic in his first six years
right and the it
he's a better
athlete it's just decision he's like a
combination of freaking Patrick mahom I
mean of Tom Brady and like some other
great quarterback that runs you know
what I mean so I already would would
take him
so that's my pick you know um and I'm so
glad that somebody said this in here you
know let let I want to talk about this
this is how I'm G finish the podcast
today is uh this idea that the NFL has
scripted okay let's talk about
this do you
understand the magnitude of that
conspiracy to be
true this is the dumbest
premise ever that people that think the
NFL is scripted and I'm gonna tell you
why how do you hide that there's three
elements okay first of all for the NFL
to be scripted all of the players would
have to be in on it all of them okay all
of the coaches all of the general
managers all of the staffs everyone
would have to
know how how is that not
leaked Tom Brady is putting deflating
balls and his dude's turned on him
you tell me how you're going to get
thousands of people to
agree that this is we're going to do
this no no no no man I don't want to
hear influenced okay no no no no no no
no no that even
that you it it it cannot be kept quiet
so that's the thing so there has to be
some and I'm G tell you why too the
second element of it is the reason why
this is ridiculous is because so there's
nobody who has gambling debts so not
only does the NFL have to be in on it
but Vegas has to be in on it too Vegas
has to be in on it and then all of the
thousands of people who are employed by
the NFL that would have to be in on it
they would not be allowed to gamble how
do you stop that you would have to be
following and keeping tabs on every
person and every person in their family
because who would do that if you knew
the outcome you saw the script you know
you're in the office and it's like you
know it's scripted we're talking about
right now how it's scripted okay like
it's scripted and you're like oh okay oh
well here's who's going to win this year
all right let's look and see uh who why
isn't there is it written down on a
piece of paper why isn't that piece of
paper surfaced by anyone so there's no
person with gambling debts or money
problems there's no person that works
for the NFL that has like a sick kid and
they don't have uh the the enough money
to pay for things that would be not be
influenced by going to TMZ and being
like I want to drop this bomb so you're
telling me that there's some sort of
wolf committee right that is making sure
no one that knows the secret is ever
going to tell it impossible human nature
doesn't work like that here's another
element of that too women listen
man you know what they say about a
woman's scorn so you're trying to tell
me that none of these baby mamas out
here have never been in the room when
when when their player got the gold
letter saying hey guys this is going to
be the script make sure you follow the
script you don't think some baby mama
that has never been paid her due or has
been treated like [__] or some wife who
got cheated on isn't going to like go
scorched Earth and be like and that's
why your game is rigged that's just what
would happen man there is no [__] way
that you would be able to keep the
entire NFL Community quiet that this
that the NFL is scripted look at my face
you're a [__] idiot if you believe
that the NFL is entirely scripted do you
understand what I'm
saying the last element of it is like
I'm saying human nature human nature man
human nature is people clout Chase
there's no way this secret would have
been leaked there's no way that there
isn't somebody who has won every NFL bet
there's no way like it would be
anomalies all over the place there would
be anomalies everywhere where Vegas
would be like yo here's a dude that won
like $100 million because he put you
know what I'm saying he's won 18 bets in
Last 5 Years nobody would keep that
secret no one look at me no one would
keep that secret no one you understand
no one would keep that secret no one no
one and there is no way that they would
be able to on the magnitude of they did
they couldn't even do the [__] in the
20s in the 20s and 30s where they tried
to rig the World Series the [__] came
out so all these people who are like so
here here's the the contention by the
idiots on the right man the far right
idiots they think because Taylor Swift
is dating Cal Travis Kelce that they've
rigged it oh my God could it possibly
be before Travis Kelce met Taylor Swift
he was already has two Super Bowls and
is the greatest tight end ever these are
the returning Champions they have
arguably the greatest quarterback ever
could it just be that they're good could
that just be it and he's a handsome
charismatic guy and this rich woman who
can't keep a boyfriend because she's a
alpha male you know what I'm saying she
got alpha male energy so of course the
only person that could date Taylor Swift
got to be a tight end in the NFL with
two Super Bowls and a lot of money in
the bank like yo you didn't make me
[__] I made me that's the only kind of
dude that could date her you know what
I'm saying so anyways it's ridiculous
okay now here's the last part the last
element why I find this to be completely
and utterly
stupid these right-wing radical nutcases
that think that the entire NFL is
scripted and this is a ploy for with
Taylor
Swift and and and my thing is like and
no one's come out with it
there's no way you can hide this
especially from the Democrats you want
to talk about stupid there isn't a
stupider group of politicians than the
liberal far liberal side some of the
dumbest some of the dumbest choices in
history Hillary Clinton saying that if
you vote for Donald Trump you're you're
uh encourageable whatever the dumb words
she used and turned a whole 70 million
people against her like they're dumb let
me tell you something right now Bill
Clinton was the president of the United
States with unlimited resources private
funds major influence and he couldn't
hide one fat chick that was sucking his
dick he couldn't hide one fat chick
sucking his dick and y'all [__]
think that the Liberals the Dum these
dummies
you think these dummies are hiding a
conspiracy of that magnitude they don't
even have the
intelligence or wherewithal to do that
who
who is it Biden the [__] can't
walk you think he's in charge of the big
NFL
conspiracy do you think that the
Liberals you think that the Democrats
have the
wherewithal okay the
wherewithal to have the gambling people
under their thumb the NFL owners under
their thumb all of these players all the
baby mamas all of the trainers all the
people you think that the Democrats have
the power and authority to stop that to
keep that Under Wraps no [__] way let
me let me say it again Bill Clinton was
the president he had Secret Service FBI
he had his own private funds he had
influence freaking he had Jeffrey
Epstein was one of his
buddies and he couldn't hide Monica
Lewinsky one chick he couldn't hide but
you think the
Democrats can hide this
conspiracy it
is stupid okay it is absolutely stupid
and I have good friends some of my best
friends who believe this and I would say
it to their [__]
face this is
stupid
now if you
think
that they want certain people to win
well yeah we're in a capitalistic
Society you guys REM listen this is how
remember when LeBron and Kobe had that
commercial with the puppets remember the
puppet
y'all remember how LeBron didn't make
the finals guys you don't think that
those companies wanted
LeBron and Kobe to play in the final of
course they did if would they try to
influence of course they would
try you don't think State Farm wanted
Aaron Rogers the
MVP to get his team to the Super Bowl
versus Patrick mahom
you don't think that they wanted that
and would do anything in their power to
make that happen if they could of course
they would now is there some referees in
the pockets of somebody could be is
there like somebody a coach who secretly
is giv the game plan to a secret
organization and they're trying to maybe
but look at my face
again it is not possible for the NFL or
NBA to be
scripted that
conspiracy the magnitude of that is
beyond capabilities in this day and age
someone would have said
something someone would have said
something
okay yes say I see someone in chat there
is a distinction between influence and
fully control of course okay I get you
but that's just the nature of why why do
you think you even have a salary cap in
the NFL NBA anyway you have a salary cap
because these rich [__] if they could
these guys got billions of dollars and
they own these teams like it's like it's
their Xbox and of course they want to
win if it was up to them they'd pay
everybody $50 million a year so they can
win championships over and over and over
again so they can look at their other
Rich guys and be like my team's better
than your team and that's why they have
a salary cap the salary cap and it
twofold it's to stop that from happening
and to make sure that the money stays in
house with them even though they have
collecting bargain agreements where 51%
or 49% of all NBA Revenue goes to the
players so no matter what they getting
paid they all split that I mean there's
so much anyways my point is
there is no like really think about it
guys they'd have to be in charge of the
gambling so you're telling me that all
these gambling places would be like oh
that they know that the information is
out there of who's going to win and you
think somebody would hide that you think
that like there's no morality and what
they're doing there like this isn't for
a good cause so therefore the people
involved in it would take advantage like
don't be stupid don't be stupid think it
through this ain't about politics I
don't give a [__] about either side they
both full of [__] they should take Biden
and Trump and put them on an island and
they should be they should those two
[__] should start a podcast and
just get out of our Lives you know what
I'm saying like I don't care about this
ain't no right-wing leftwing thing they
just it's
stupid and the people that believe that
this is something going on on with the
the left isn't smart enough to do this
they ain't smart enough for this man
they just not
they busy cancelling people they're in
an echo cham the left is in an echo
chamber yelling at themselves about
gender and fat people and and freaking
you know all that stuff and then the the
right they they out here they listening
to Fox News and what do they know they
out here they don't care about gun
control they don't care about you know
what I'm saying we got other issues
there's no way that this this thing
could be
done all
right uh anyways guys um that's
it that's GNA be it for today that's
going to be it for today uh I'm G be
back to normal like now again make sure
you check out um every Monday guys
Mondays I'm doing my uh a supplemental
podcast I do um you know Nuance it's
it's Monday morning Nuance I call it
Monday morning Nuance so come check me
out there so you could see me talking
about different things since I have one
topic you know I do like uh I'm going do
some q&as and stuff like that but I got
it's more me talking about stuff on
Monday mornings and you can watch it
live on Twitch if you are a subscriber
you can watch it live on ttch subscribe
you get like a little taste of it for
like five minutes and then they turn it
off because you're if you're not a
subscriber if you're a subscriber or VIP
on my twitch you could get that and if
you want to subscribe on Twitch you see
see a lot of me doing gaming and stuff
like that which is great but you can
also you know get on uh like I say um
make sure you subscribe follow hit the
notification so you can see me uh coming
going live you know what I mean and uh
you know it is what it is y'all it is
what it is wait no my music came on
that's not what I was looking for I let
me get my um I'm I'm not prepared today
because it's just been like I've been
tired man the child having a child is
everything people says it is in terms of
like um being tired it's crazy you know
it is absolutely crazy all right anyways
let me get my guy let me see what what
long this is okay yeah yeah it's that
rap
recap
woo Daddy's back everybody
clap
[Music]
uh got a new
Baby Woo he got that Swag Like Patrick
[Music]
S I'm so tired eyes feeling
hazy can't believe it this shit's
crazy anyways y'all thanks for watching
Griffin with Griffin I'm here every
Wednesday live every Monday live from
for subscribers and patreon members I
appreciate you guys being here make sure
you hit me with your comments uh you
know if you have some questions let's
keep the conversation going about
fatherhood I want to keep talking about
it in week weeks and weeks and weeks to
come so you guys can see where I'm at on
my journey and I appreciate you and I
will see you next
week
[Music]